all right hopefully you've had enough
time to watch spiderman no way home
because it's my spiderman no way home
spoiler talk warning you right out the
gate this is the video in which i spoil
the movie after the rest of the internet
already spoiled the movie but first i do
want to give some loving love to the
sponsor this video this video is brought
to you by amc plus amc plus is the
premium streaming bundle that offers all
your heart's desire from dystopian
wastelands to other halloween treats
that we all crave in these cheery
holiday times shows like gangs of london
the new series firebite which premiered
on december 16th creep show seasons one
and two which surprisingly captures the
spirit of 1980s horror and amc plus is
offering you a special holiday deal of
just 1.99 a month with an annual
membership because we all love that
glorious winter wonderland as much as
the next person but sometimes you gotta
splatter a little gore in there so click
the link below enjoy this season of
holiday
see ya
and thank you once again to amc plus for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
alright and now
the time has come not much more i'm
warning you about not many more ways i
can warn you if you're still clocked
into this video you've officially been
warned also like all my spoiler talks
this isn't going to be a play-by-play
there will be things that you'll be like
oh i wish you talked about that then i'm
just probably going to skip over it
happens with these things you know it's
just forewarning you don't worry i'll
talk about the big ones you know the
supporting cast members that we already
knew about because those [ __ ]
internet leaks so spiderman no way home
one of the most difficult reviews i've
ever done on this channel because the
plot actually is yes like i said in my
spoiler free review all these villains
from the multiverse from other
spider-man movies come to battle
spider-man but on the other hand he gets
help from
tubby mcguire and andrew garfield
spider-man yes all three of them are in
this movie which would have been
the most
epic
upon epic reveals
ever like just cinematically
holy [ __ ] but internet being the
internet leaked pics went around of
course
it was just ruined actually when i was
watching the movie because when you're
watching the movie you're like how real
were the pics but the moment i saw matt
murdock's cane i was like okay well that
pick was real which means the other pick
fought three of them andrew garfield
toby maguire and tom holland well that
pick's got to be real too it's all part
of the same set both reveals would have
been
something else just next level to see on
screen for the first time but what
really impressed me i know i'm skipping
ahead i'm skipping ahead to the part
where the three spider-mans are working
together in the movie because that's
that's what we want to hear it's a
spoiler video among a movie that answers
that simple question what to do if you
and your friends don't get into that
same college well the answer is clear
hope you know a wizard who's willing to
brainwash the entire world what else
would you do a wizard who i guess he's
not sorcerer supreme anymore but i was
really impressed with how long andrew
garfield and toby maguire were in this
movie i thought they were just gonna
come in at the very end just all right
we're here for the end fight now the end
fight's happening you know nostalgia
that wasn't the case they were actually
support characters in this movie i
really appreciated that this happens
when ned lee just like oh i want to see
peter parker and he starts creating
portals because i guess he can do that
that's the character in my spoiler free
review i was like there's a character
who's kind of pulls an ability out of
his ass he's never been able to do
before it's this yeah that ability that
the sorcerer supreme former sorcerer's
supreme had to get sent to mount everest
or wherever to fight for his life like
okay life or death got to make a portal
he finally made a portal ned leeds can
just kind of do it
power of belief but glad to what it led
to because at first when i saw it
spider-man was like oh hey here comes
spider-man
that is not tom holland's suit oh wow
but here it is so what's happening
andrew garfield comes on screen okay i
mean for real probably an unpopular
opinion i've always thought andrew
garfield was great as peter parker and
spider-man thought he was a great choice
i thought he did a great job you say
what you want about his movies but i
felt he did a good job and i'm hoping
that people can see that in here you
know i hope this is a movie that you
know the amazing spider-man stigma you
know it's it's not here so my hope is
that people can see andrew garfield in
this movie and be like oh
outside the amazing spider-man in this
movie it's easier to see that yeah
he does do a good job in this role i
mean his charisma from right when he
shows up and when he's in scenes with
tom holland and toby mcguire the dude
oozes charisma i thought they all had
great chemistry together i also liked
how it showed their different peter
parker elements you know they were how
they're brilliant and different things
tom holland when he's fighting doctor
strange it was like oh this world's just
it's all geometry i know geometry and he
basically uses geometry to trap dr
strange in that mirror dimension so it
shows that he's brilliant at math and
geometry you see andrew garfield and he
has the lab coat you know he's the
scientist toby mcguire's the
really cool youth pastor come on it's
like one of the best lines in the movie
delivered by andrew garfield but it was
that scene specifically when andrew
garfield had the lab coat it's just a
visual cue that i have from of that
that moment that eureka moment that i
had with this movie where i was like
that's not just bringing these guys in
to fight these they're actually
supporting cast members
that's unexpectedly amazing also willem
dafoe is green goblin when i saw him
have the purple hoodie and the green
coat i was like oh that's a great
callback and then that reveal where he's
the goblin and he starts fighting peter
parker and that hoodie starts getting
shredded i was like
oh my gosh he's gonna have the hoodie
he's gonna have the purple cap i give
this movie props man it's like they
listen to anyone and everyone who was
ever like man william defoe is perfect
you don't even need to have him wear a
mask and they were like okay
we won't i thought the green goblin's
costume design you know he had his green
goblin armor but he had willem dafoe's
face with a purple hoodie that's all
shredded and tattered i was like that is
it's a really good costume design he's
all laughing
and spiderman's just beating the [ __ ]
out of him i was like dude
green goblin is like the peak villain in
this movie i mean other villains yeah
they gotta deal with that they're
problems but green goblin man it's
another movie where green goblin's the
villain hey there's the return of green
goblin how rad is that yeah i'm not
gonna skip over that he totally kills
aunt may but i'm glad aunt may said with
great power comes great responsibility
to peter parker and the other spidermans
were like whoa uncle ben used to say
that that's a great moment but man when
the glider smashed into her i was like
well she died immediately like broke in
half just
i thought she just came apart
it made like the cat from boondock
saints like if anyone was like is she
dead i'd be like
of course she
that's even a question then she's all
like
yeah i'm good i'm good just
um
man that'll uh that first step right am
i right it's whoa
oh
yeah just gotta work that out i'm good
pete how you doing i was like there's no
[ __ ] way there's what is she super
powered now ned leeds can make portals
aunt may's
impervious to damage then she starts
slowly collapsing and and then she dies
is actually a really sad scene and tom
holland when he's toe to toe with the
green goblin who comes back you know
they're carrying everybody they rewire
the chip on otto octavius's neck so now
he's good which also shows it took tom
holland spider-man a piece of tech to do
that which toby maguire's spider-man did
with words but when green goblin shows
up post aunt may death dude spider-man
tom holland spider-man is duking it out
with him and he does that ground punch
where you just dents the ground it's
like that would have killed him he tried
to kill him he ends up carrying him
because they gotta cure them all and
that's what makes spider-man a hero and
at the end when doctor strange comes
back so from doctor strange being gone
to now it's felt like peter parker
spider-man's movie the spider-man's is
the peter parker's but doctor strange is
trying to contain it and it's all
ripping open that's when you just be on
the lookout in that scene because you
see a lot of spider-man villains in
there the ones i think i think i saw
craven um scorpion rhino
that's that's where multiple viewings
will come in so guys look in there
before now i'm gonna have to look to the
left but those are the ones i saw in my
first viewing and actually given props
where i forgot to give props before
zendaya i thought was really good in
this movie her relationship with peter
parker's been a weird one for me i
haven't really
bought it i haven't felt it like i felt
andrew garfield peter parker and gwen
stacy or toby mcguire peter parker and
mary jane you know mj and peter parker
in this franchise have always been like
it just it lacked something in the last
movie she was just like you're
spider-man i've known for a while it's
kind of like all right well that's a way
to do it
didn't grab me but that is certainly a
choice i mean for nothing else i wish we
had more opportunities to see the person
behind that wall she puts up but to be
fair this is the movie where you finally
do see that right before she forgets him
entirely but at the end of this movie
peter parker's like all right strange
have everybody forget
about peter parker period i mean aunt
may's dead really doesn't have anybody
he's going to lose his friend ned leeds
and mj but
that's that's the price to pay to save
the multiverse because i tried to get
them into college the prospect of
forgetting him entirely you could tell
that she was
shaken by that fact you know shaken by
the thought she's like i i don't want to
do this i don't want to do this i was
feeling it at the end you know he goes
into the diner and he's talking with her
and how do you open that dialogue well
yeah we saved the multiverse and we were
in love but i imagine peter won't give
up young love shall be sparked again so
that's what happens everyone forgets
about peter parker because all the
villains whoever knew peter parker with
spider-man are coming through this
portal and so everyone forgets the peter
parker's spider-man
and so the multiverse is fixed and then
everyone goes back but also the villains
are cured so everyone goes back and they
don't have to die
except doc ock still will because he
knew peter parker was spider-man and it
was right before he died and it was when
he said that the octopus arm the
tentacle was around his neck so it had
to be that scene of spider-man 2 right
before peter parker gave the big speech
it turned him good which means right
after that he dies good anyway so he's
going to go back to that moment and
still be good
but that self-sustaining ball of energy
that's a little sun
is still that still happened so we still
gonna have to die a hero i mean die to
hero before he's gonna die a hero now
the tragic fate of doc ock i guess but i
take solace in knowing that he always
dies a good man at the end i kind of
geeked out it showed that he sews his
own suit he makes his own spider-man
suit that looks remarkably like an
old-school spider-man suit from the
comic books everyone in the mcu has
forgotten about peter parker being
spider-man or that peter parker was ever
a human being so it's like this movie
took spider-man
away from all that and placed spider-man
in the spider-man bubble
of spider-man adventures that he now
gets to do which means we were kind of
duped my friends we saw spider-man in
the mcu we saw spider-man homecoming and
we were like whoa it's a spider-man
movie with no real spider-man origin
story they just skipped over that
because we've seen it before cuts to the
chase gets right to the point no this
whole trilogy has been the longest
spider-man origin story ever the
post-credits scenes were cool also a
little confusing the first one the
mid-credits scene is uh eddie brock is
just at this bar
and he's like okay so there was a tin
man and he flies and then he died and
then and he just disappears yeah eddie
brock came to this world to get removed
from this world he came to leave he's
like that person that shows up to the
party eats a couple of a couple of the
treats he's like all right peace i'm out
all right glad you could stay for seven
minutes but he leaves a little bit of
the symbiote behind so it leaves it open
for peter parker to get the black suit
possibly
another eddie brock
could do the whole thing over again
competing venoms man sony's like i mean
venom's a money maker let's do that
again the end credit scene is doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
trailer which looks really cool it's
kind of like what happened at the end
of uh captain america where i was like
okay here's your trailer for the
avengers that's your post credit scene
now guys in the end i really dug
spider-man no way home the first hour of
the movie or so is
a spider-man fetch quest where he has to
trap villains shoot him with this doctor
strange web shooter thing and trapped
him into a cell but when andrew garfield
and toby maguire join the fray the
dynamic between the three spider-mans
the three peter parkers that's where the
movie really shines and it's not just
the familiarity of these spider-man
heroes that we've seen before in the
spider-man villains we've seen before
the chemistry among toby maguire andrew
garfield and tom holland that's really
where the movie hits its peak hits its
stride you see no one in this movie
phoned it in i love that i love the fact
that they could have you know could have
been andrew garfield shows up he's like
yes wait just give me my paycheck it's
not like it's really my movie anyway
toby mcguire could have been like sweet
let's get me a paycheck
i haven't been spider-man for ever
just give me my paycheck alfred molina
willem dafoe they could have just been
like yep give me the paycheck that's
what actors do in these situations right
they come back to this nostalgic thing
for this nostalgic moment they just
phone it in and get their paycheck but
they didn't everybody jamie foxx alfred
molina willem dafoe toby maguire andrew
garfield none of them phoned it in they
were like let's do the character the
movie the franchise and most importantly
the fans justice i appreciate the hell
out of that and to be fair i have seen
the argument in the comment section
because i have railed on movies relying
too much on nostalgias like it's just
nostalgia
seems really familiar like they're
cheaply trying to emulate something that
happened before in this franchise and i
saw people ask me in the comment section
of my spoiler free review for this movie
where they're like how is this any
different how do you like this nostalgia
but you rail on some of the nostalgia
you've seen other movies do and the best
i can describe if i'm gonna
tell you how my brain is processing it
this movie spiderman no way home
still treats the characters like
characters it doesn't just bring the
characters on screen to be like oh
they're on screen and that's good enough
you're on screen for about five minutes
in the last act we got him no toby
maguire and andrew garfield are in this
movie as legit support characters also
another thing i see nostalgia bait
movies do that this movie didn't do is
try to recreate settings or scenarios
where it's like the new movie is dlc
skin over the old movie where it may
look a little different but it's the
same thing for my money spider-man no
way home just didn't feel like that for
me it wasn't just a blatant retread for
the sake of making a sequel and some of
the damaged heroes find new closure mj
gets dropped spider-man's girlfriend
getting dropped off of a high-rise is a
familiar scenario but it did use that
scenario to give andrew garfield's
character closure so for nothing else
this is at least making an attempt to be
amazing spider-man 2.5 it had its own
action sequences all three spider-man's
on screen fighting the villains was
pretty [ __ ] awesome and that it has
fan service but it had its own scenarios
had its own stakes it did the nostalgia
weaving better than i've seen a lot of
movies do lately so for my money that's
how i see it so spoiler talk there we go
gotta edit this one together but i am
thrilled to ask you spiderman no way
home have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you